I went to Ecuador with Scots tribbles
rainforest class in March of 2008 I was
a member of the first sort of academic
ornithological expedition ever yeah that
yells ever done and went to Ecuador we
free Crum I went to - Chicago which is
an island off the coast of Puerto Rico
to do research with rhesus macaques
I gotta go to Sicily as part of class
global tectonics is over spring break
yeah we're actually working geologists
for trapeese
you guys might not believe this but this
is what we are doing on our vacation
the courses that we have is centered on
the idea that the students are going to
collect plant samples that they're going
to then study for the summer now they
bring them back to Yale and from there
they isolate microbes and we end up with
a case that students have anywhere from
50 to 100 microbes each many of which
are novel in fact it's quite routine for
these students to identify microbes that
are novel at the level of genus I've
found a new genus as well so yeah well
taken away from it was really just kind
of the adventure of going out and
experiencing science in the field a lot
of time we get stuck in lab and I know
since then I've been in lab 10 to 20
maybe even 30 hours a week but going
there in the initial part you kind of
got a sense of how much fun it can be to
just kind of go out and see what you
find it sort of made science a very
creative interacting experience rather
than just your typical reading textbooks
instead we were actually practicing and
doing science rather than learning what
others have done so we're isolating
microbes that could have utility and use
and become model systems for various
types of investigation including things
related to biofuels and natural product
production it gives you a sense of how
huge the scope of science can be if you
let it be and instead of just focusing
it on like the test tube you're looking
at
the idea was to take them to a place
where there are lots of diverse geologic
phenomena things that are going on right
now volcanoes or earthquakes other kinds
of events and to directly expose them to
earth history most important you'll read
about something because I know memorize
like tests about it but once you
actually see it in the field or see two
concepts that you learn in three
chapters apart look right next to each
other everything sort of the actual
collision zone is down in southern
Sicily here the leading edge the active
active fault between Africa and Europe
is is you can actually put your hand on
this region he took a ferry out of the
Ionian islands and climbed on Stromboli
in a day and that was something that was
just incredible because I never done
anything like that I'm not a hiker a
nature girl okay either people are out
there if you can hear the sound know
it's died down a little bit before
there's a tremendous sort of almost
deafening avalanche done it's not a very
high volcano but it's actively erupting
all the time you hear this boom and
suddenly you see globs of lava going up
in the air and it's really quite
stunning and in fact a little bit of
impressive that they actually let you to
go up there I had to wear helmets and we
stopped halfway up and really get what
we were wearing helmets I thought it was
just a liability thing I'm here this
huge explosion and our guys said well
you need to keep in mind that there's
there's explosive rock flying off the
mountain once we got to the top we can
actually see magma exploding this isn't
like kind of lava that you see in Hawaii
were kind of nicely boozes out you can
walk up to it and this is explosive lava
that we were looking at coming climbing
down it was a
Ashley's like running down the Sandhills
this is home anything this is really
cool we're like kind of snowshoeing down
some dirt it took us a few hours to get
up in probably 45 minutes to get down
just cuz we got to run down the hill as
fast as we could sounds really cool the
reason we study monkeys is were actually
interested in how humans make sense of
the world and what we want to do is take
an evolutionary approach so we actually
study how monkeys make sense of their
world to try to figure out how humans do
and what aspects of how we think might
actually be unique to humans and what
are the kinds of things that might be
shared with monkeys there are just
monkeys everywhere you look it's not a
zoo they don't live in cages they're
completely free-ranging this is
tolerance session - were 31 J and 61 are
just made it that much more interesting
and that much more practical to learn
more about primary social behavior in
the field and in the natural setting as
opposed to in a lab where a lot of the
social behavior is governed by the fact
that they are in a lab so I conducted a
study looking at in-group out-group
biases monkey racism we wanted to see if
rhesus macaques also display the same
biases that humans do
my specific question had to do with
mating behavior and the rhesus macaque
monkeys 25n and 51a the cues that male
rhesus macaques pick up on when female
versus macaques are sort of fertile or
ready for mating and if they incorporate
that into attraction in the time I've
been at Yale I've been able to go down
there with about fifty different
undergraduate students who've gone down
there and helped me with research and
since then we've had about twenty
publications with undergraduate students
ended up presenting my results at a
conference last April the Society for
research and child development in Denver
we're getting published our study is
getting published in a scientific
journal it really just gives
undergraduates the opportunity to be
real collaborators by being able to go
down to this field site and study these
questions made me feel for the first
time like an actual scientist the
experience of going outside and actually
using your senses to engage with
biodiversity itself is something that
you can't learn in the classroom Yale
students have a great education in
testing hypotheses and analyzing data
and discussing ideas and figuring out
ways to test them but their classroom
education cannot give them another
essential element which is going outside
and using your senses using your wits to
observe biodiversity to record it and to
understand how it lives yes
pretty excited so we wake up very early
in the morning normally four to five six
was lucky am generally closer to four
and then for the next 18 to 20 hours
you're pretty much outside bird watching
there on the trunk of the tree now it's
so intense and there's so many things
that you have to take in and ones that
it's almost overwhelming but it's
because you have people there that
really know what they're talking about
they and are great teachers it was
really a really incredible experience in
the Amazon we climbed this huge huge
rickety wooden Tower and were able to
stand out over all the trees and just
see bird after bird after bird they just
kept coming and we saw two kids and
parents would fly over squawking and I
really don't like Heights that much I
was completely afraid we went up there
it was just so cool
here we are 37 meters above the rain
forest for in the canopy and Ecuador and
we've seen lemon throated bar pants and
three plum proteges tingles in the same
tree it was exquisite
you can't wait to find out what go see
next I think it's very important to see
things in their natural habitat the way
they really are
I'm calling flying around building nests
I mean it's totally it's a totally
different totally different experience
than getting the context is very
important
the most memorable part of the trip was
probably the oil bird cave seeing an oil
bird cave is one of the most bizarre
ornithological experiences you can have
all of a sudden we heard this screaming
noise and there were these largest birds
flying overhead and making both
screaming noises and these weird
clicking they were echolocating and then
we turned on the flashlights and then on
every little ledge there was there were
one or two of the chips and the chicks
were actually bigger than the adults it
was terrifying at one you know on one
hand but it was also really cool it's
really fantastic to show it took some to
the very edges of ornithological
experience asked me about my experience
in Puerto Rico I always say that it was
the most rewarding experience I've ever
had in Yale it was an opportunity that I
don't think I could get anywhere else
I was a perspective major and then this
kind of pushed me over the edge into
geology coming in I always said I wanted
to go to law school and now definitely
think about masters and PhD programs I'm
taking a lot of science classes this
year I'm a bio physics major
but yeah the class is definitely spurred
uh an interest in science me for the
rest of my life for me at least now I'm
so excited about going to new places and
finding new things that I think no
matter what I do I want to incorporate
that it really got me engaged in
outreach and looking at international
collaboration and now whenever I think
about science research I think about
going abroad and looking at resources
that no one's looked at it definitely
has shaped how I think I'll be
interacting with the science community
in the future when I heard the Brook was
doing this trip I was actually pre-med
and and so we kind of rethought my
priorities and decided that that's what
I wanted to do and someone who was
wasn't sure about setting biology in
general it totally changed my
perspective it really made me switch
over to evolutionary biology
man